welcome to council of geeks i'm joined
once again by paul scavito and ryan daly
and as you may have guessed from paul's
maniacal grin we're gonna talk about the
confirmed casting of benedict
cumberbatch as dr strange
and so yes i'm a little fired up about
it to come back like doctor strange well
it's funny i remember when we talked
when we did our our marvel round table
like
way way a while ago
you just you threw it out as a bit of
fantastic yes and and now
dreams do come true prescient
i i think that benedict cumberbatch can
completely own this part and in a
completely serious manner we've seen
this arrogant character arrogant aloof
character before in the form of sherlock
the fear being are we going to see
sherlock again
my answer to that is no
i don't think we're going to see that
character again because he played
something very similar in khan
and they are distinctly different
characters i think that benedict
cumberbatch has enough depth as an actor
that he can give us this different one
and i actually have a third example to
point to um for this which is that um
his depiction of victor frankenstein on
stage on stage is a distinctly different
character from sherlock from khan and
yet if you were to dissect those
characters they are essentially arrogant
characters who are full of themselves
and hubris and yet they are very
distinct versions they are very distinct
characters it kind of feels like almost
fan desire willed this into reality
because that
that scares me though not because it
gives him power
i think i think marvel is smart enough
to realize when what the fans want is a
good idea and when what the fans want is
a bad idea but i think they're also
tuned in enough to their fans to go
oh you know what they're right
let's let's go with that i just like
that vibe
i think everything that you said makes
sense and i agree with everything you
said i have one real substantive concern
up to this point i haven't heard
benedict cumberbatch do an american
accent that i liked
and i think it is i think it's important
that this character be american because
he's not a grown-up harry potter he is
america's magician he is not that old
world type type of wizardry that you get
from europe and their mythology he is a
beatnik from greenwich village
um it's a very different take and i i
think that is important that he be
played as an american
yeah that's a fair point that's nothing
new that's good that's my one and again
yep
and maybe it won't matter if everything
else clicks that that is not going to be
a deal breaker for me the other sort of
major marvel casting announcement that
came around was kristin ritter advanced
from breaking bad and don't trust the
bee in apartment 23.
i'm sure that had fans she's been cast
as jessica jones in the newly
rechristened aka jessica jones which
will be the follow-up to daredevil on
marvel's netflix site which is confirmed
to be coming out in 2015. i
know of jessica jones i never really
read alias i've read you know what the
notion what the premise is i think it's
a cool idea
but this this is one of those properties
that i'm certainly interested to see
what they do with it
i don't have a dog in this race though i
just don't
know enough about her as an actress she
must have nailed the audition i guess
sure i mean they're going to have to
show me something in a form of a trailer
or something right that's absolutely on
board yeah i watched i watched clips
from that show and i've watched her
doing interviews and she just she comes
off as a very manic
high-energy comedic personality
which is about as far as you can get
from the source material as there is
um jessica jones in the comics is very
abrasive she's a hard character to like
i think in breaking bad we saw kristen
ritter play some vulnerability and some
pain but the character of jessica jones
has much more of a hard edge
and i don't see that in the actress
because she looks like she weighs 30
pounds um and jessica jones looks like
somebody who would start and win a bar
fight in the comics her story is dark
her whole launch was one of the big
impetuses for the for the max line right
right marvel and they made it an adult a
mature reader's title and i can see the
netflix series
not going as dark as the comics do to go
down that line i think it's going to be
tough bouncing and i think we'll
probably get a better sense of how far
they're going to be able to push it when
we see daredevil
because i i have a feeling that these
series these netflix series are going to
be deliberately a bit darker and a bit
more mature than the movies are they're
going to operate in sort of that funny
gray area that like the tv 14
raiding operates in which is
more than pg-13 but not quite an r right
from what you're telling me that's still
a few steps down from what the actual
source material is it's it would be an r
if they downplay that character a little
bit
i have an easier time seeing connecting
it with this actress who i see as much
more of a comedic almost flighty actress
but again it boils down to trust and yep
how many times does marvel let us down i
was gonna say that that i i think one of
the jobs in front of marvel for these
shows totally these shows need to be
different than um i would say three
things going on right now one of them is
shield and they also need to be in
contrast to um
really mostly aero
um yeah and um which is dc's one sort of
popular television series and and gotham
although gotham is we could have a whole
different conversation about gotham and
what that is but um so i think what
we're going to see from these is
serious
darker not as dark
as
um as it could be but
um i think tonally
um i think fans are actually gonna be
really happy with the stuff that that
marvel is doing on netflix i i i think
they're gonna be telling serious stories
i think they're gonna be telling stories
that
probably shock viewers from time to time
i think they're really going to be
taking some risks the the fact that it
is confirmed to come out in 2015 so
from marvel in 2015 their whole output
will include agent carter starting in
january and going through february super
fired up um followed by
shield season 2.5 avengers age of ultron
yep daredevil
aka jessica jones and ant-man two movies
two netflix series and two different
television series
nothing coming out from dc or warner
brothers nothing coming out from sony or
fox like the superhero comic book world
i think is
all marvel studios next year
mar marvel owns 2015. and i i think
we're all okay with that
so i think this is the perfect casting
of any part ever and i think that just
they made this decision for
all of us the world and the next
generation also the children who are the
future and i think that putting benedict
cumberbatch in the role is going to fix
most of what's wrong um
with the world i think that like we're
gonna once this movie comes out we're
gonna figure out that whole like global
warming thing
and like like just peace um